Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
Buonasera a tutti.
Io vorrei dirvi, per cominciare,
una frase che usò
Lyndon Johnson quando
pochi giorni dopo la scomparsa
del Presidente Kennedy,
si presentò davanti
al Congresso degli Stati Uniti
e disse: “Darei tutto quello che ho
perché potesse essere lui
a parlarvi e non io”.
Per me è la stessa cosa stasera.
Io ho avuto la fortuna
di conoscere Antonia Terzi
e posso dirvi che anche lei,
nel suo piccolo, nel suo grande,
come John Kennedy,
aveva in mente la nuova frontiera.
La nuova frontiera di una donna
che ha osato quello che sembrava
inosabile per tantissimo tempo.
E se avrete la pazienza
di seguire la mia narrazione
forse comprenderete perché uso
questi paragoni in apparenza audaci.
Penso che siate tutti consapevoli
che l’automobilismo,
la Formula 1 in particolare,
sono mondi che hanno sempre avuto
nel DNA il maschilismo.
Se voi recuperate le immagini
di un secolo di corse,
non troverete mai figure femminili
in ruoli di responsabilità:
non vi parlo solo dei piloti,
che potreste liquidare l’argomento
con quella battuta stupidissima
“Donna al volante, pericolo costante”,
dico proprio a livello manageriale,
a livello progettuale,
a livello ingegneristico.
Se c’è stato un settore nel quale
la figura della donna era
rigorosamente limitata
ad una presenza,
vorrei dire, coreografica,
quello sicuramente era
l’universo dei motori.
Io ho iniziato molto presto
a frequentare i circuiti
per la mia passione, per il mio mestiere,
e le donne che si vedevano negli autodromi
erano le mogli o le compagne dei piloti
oppure, dopo qualche tempo,
le ragazze che si occupavano
delle relazioni esterne,
della comunicazione.
Era assolutamente inimmaginabile
supporre che ci fosse una donna
tra tutti quegli uomini
con un ruolo di responsabilità
esteso alle più sofisticate
competenze tecnologiche.
Ora, voi dovete immaginare
una bambina, una ragazzina
che frequentava il gruppo degli scout
nella Bassa Modenese
e che appunto era Antonia e che stasera
avrebbe dovuto parlare qui al mio posto,
dovete immaginare
quella bambina, quella ragazzina
che quando comincia a crescere
dice ai suoi coetanei:
“Ma io mi voglio occupare di automobili,
voglio disegnare vetture,
voglio essere l’artefice
di quella che è l’espressione altissima
della velocità, quindi la Formula 1".
E io vi assicuro, appunto,
perché ho avuto il piacere di
farmi raccontare le sue storie,
che mentre coltivava questi sogni,
al di là della sua famiglia meravigliosa,
era circondata dallo scetticismo generale.
I suoi amici e le sue amiche le dicevano:
“Cosa? Una donna che disegna una Ferrari?”
Mah, forse per un compito in classe,
forse per un’illustrazione
da appendere a una festa di carnevale.
Figuriamoci se può accadere
nel mondo reale,
dove appunto sono tutti maschi,
sono tutti uomini.
Ecco io penso che quando si parla
di nuova frontiera,
e si parla anche di esempio per tutti noi,
l’esempio che Antonia
ha saputo dare è proprio questo,
che quel soffitto di vetro,
Shining Glass come dicono gli americani,
che abitualmente ancora oggi
nella nostra società
è una sorta di tetto non sfondabile
da parte dell’elemento femminile,
poteva invece essere mandato in frantumi.
Perché poi, questa storia come va avanti?
Va avanti che questa ragazza studia,
si prende la sua laurea in ingegneria
e non si accontenta,
non pensa di mettere in bacheca
il titolo di studio
ma va avanti
perché quello che diceva da bambina,
da ragazzina, da coccinella degli scout,
“Io un giorno, un giorno
disegnerò la Ferrari”,
vuole che diventi verità,
che diventi realtà.
E a un certo punto cosa succede?
Succede che siamo, vent’anni fa
più o meno, nell’epoca d’oro,
visto che quindi di dietro, della Ferrari
di Montezemolo, Todt, Schumi, eccetera,
io sono a un Gran Premio
in Germania, a Hockenheim,
e mi accorgo che c’è
una signorina, una ragazza,
con le cuffie alle orecchie,
quelle famose che tengono- per contenere
i rumori dei bolidi da Gran Premio,
nel paddock della Ferrari,
nel garage della Ferrari.
E devo dirvi, da maschilista o comunque
da appartenente a quel mondo,
che istintivamente penso che sia
un’altra addetta alle comunicazioni.
Perché di solito le donne
in Formula 1 quello facevano
e debbo dire ancora oggi
in larga parte fanno:
se guardate Hamilton, Verstappen,
di ingegneri donna al box dalla Mercedes
o della Red Bull non è
che ne vediate tanti, eh.
Però mi incuriosisce questa figura,
questa presenza e quindi
raccolgo informazioni e
con mia sorpresa assoluta mi dicono
“No no, ma che addetta alla comunicazione,
questa è una dei responsabili
dell’aerodinamica
della macchina rossa di Michael Schumacher
che sta vincendo tutte le gare
possibili e immaginabili”.
E io ho fatto così questa scoperta
bellissima e clamorosa,
che quel famoso tetto di vetro,
che è un ostacolo permanente, spesso
ancora oggi nella nostra società,
da qualcuno era stato sfondato
nel mondo più maschilista che ci sia,
che è quello dell’automobilismo.
Ed è questo che ha fatto Antonia Terzi.
Se voi ogni tanto fate un giro su Youtube
eccetera e andate a vedere
quella macchina di Schumacher
che vinceva sempre
della quale oggi noi qui
abbiamo tutti grande nostalgia,
perché purtroppo nel presente la Ferrari
non si può dire che sia competitiva,
ecco, guardatevela e rendetevi conto che
quelle linee fantastiche, strepitose
efficientissime, eccetera,
sono state tracciate da Antonia
che senza nessuna raccomandazione,
esclusivamente con la forza
della sua passione,
della sua competenza, della sua cultura,
ha saputo fare tutto questo
a nome, io penso, di tutte le donne.
Perché quando ci raccontiamo che sì,
appunto, i progressi, la società,
la fine dell’emarginazione,
l’equiparazione e così
sono tutti bellissimi slogan.
Però abbiamo bisogno di esempi,
di cose concrete, di episodi autentici
che vengono a suffragare
questi slogan, appunto.
E Antonia Terzi
ha saputo fare tutto questo.
Lo ha fatto all’interno dell’azienda che è
il brand italiano più conosciuto nel mondo
e lo ha fatto talmente bene
che poi è andata anche
a lavorare per la concorrenza.
Perché l’hanno chiamata la Williams, poi
successivamente è rimasta nell’ambiente,
è stata responsabile tecnico
di Bentley e tutto il resto.
Allora quello che io voglio dirvi,
e mi dispiace che non ve lo possa dire
lei, stasera, di persona,
è che questa nuova frontiera kennediana,
qui vicino fra la Bassa Modenese,
Fiorano, Maranello,
è già stata raggiunta,
è stata raggiunta non troppo tempo fa,
è stata tracciata una rotta
e io dico sempre tutti gli anni,
quando mi capita di dovermi occupare
di una nuova macchina da corsa,
domando sempre: “Quante donne ci sono che
lavorano su questa macchina?”
Ma non sulla comunicazione e non per
prendere nota dei tempi e tutto il resto
o per seguire sul computer le chat,
WhatsApp, e tutte queste robe che sapete.
No no, che che cercano di
far andare quella macchina più forte,
come è stata capace di fare Antonia Terzi.
Questa è una grandissima lezione,
è una testimonianza di vita
che io mi auguro
non rimanga fine a se stessa
e che soprattutto, come vi ho detto,
possa trasformarsi in un esempio,
in una-, visto che siamo sotto Natale,
in una stella luminosa da seguire
per tutte le ragazze che magari
ancora oggi fanno parte
dei gruppi boy scout e che sognano,
immaginano di poter vivere da protagoniste
in un mondo, in una realtà,
che deve smettere di essere dominata
dalla dittatura maschilista.
Questo è quello che
ha insegnato Antonia Terzi,
questo, io credo,
avrebbe voluto dirvi lei stasera,
e io mi scuso con voi se
indegnamente l’ho sostituita,
ma veramente mi ha fatto
un piacere immenso
poter spendere questo tempo per
dedicare qualche parola in suo ricordo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)